[Music]
imagine spending
five years of your life fighting to
survive
[Music]
finding ways out of dangerous situations
time and
time again abandoned mike whoa whoa
jesus christ oh my god get me out get
out get me up get me the [ __ ] out
holy sh traveling across thousands of
miles of unfamiliar territory while
building your
world around you this might be the last
time we see
everything in this world just to have it
all vanish
in an instant no
but what if one of the most
soul-crushing moments of your life
became your crowning achievement well
for minecraft streamer filza
that's exactly what happened of all the
things
it was gonna be something stupid i knew
i knew so by the time his whole world
came crashing
down filza had been playing minecraft
for about eight years
he tried all kinds of different modes
but hardcore was the one that really
stuck
and filzo wasn't playing for views or
money he genuinely enjoyed living his
best minecraft life streaming his
adventures to maybe
five or ten regulars who came along for
the ride i've always done this as like a
hobby
like i didn't care about getting tons of
views
that wasn't was never my goal now
there's something you have to understand
hardcore mode is exactly what it sounds
like
whether you're playing single player
multiplayer it's a brutally unforgiving
experience
one mistake and everything you've
accomplished
is gone ah
what
there's no response there's no second
chances you're living on the edge
every day and to really up the ante
there's no
changing difficulties a hardcore account
is only a hardcore account
it just kind of felt like everything you
did was a lot more significant
and everything you accomplished had more
weight to it
because you did it all on one life and
it's cool to look back and look at all
these cool things that you did
on that one life on the hardest
difficulty for a few truly exceptional
players a single run will maybe last a
few weeks a few months
tops for everyone else it's even shorter
than that is that herobrine
oh god now you're gonna die
but in phil's case not only did he
survive in his world
he thrived in it for five years
what wow never text
abandoned mike oh wow jesus christ
oh my god get me out give me give me up
get me the [ __ ] out
holy sh oh my god i got
pranked i got lured in i got launched
off here
landed here and then after i landed i
got the buffs after walking around a bit
but all of that changed on april 24th
2019 when the unthinkable happened
you see during one of his usual streams
filza landed in a cave
full of enchanted baby zombies yeah
you heard that right realizing the
danger he was in
philza decided to run but his effort
was all in vain no really
that's how i die oh my god i'm
stupid and that's how a baby zombie
murdered what's possibly
the longest hardcore run in the history
of minecraft
to say that filza was devastated would
be a giant understatement
i tried as well i realized i realized i
was
and i still went for the golden apple i
should have went for the the taunt of
undying
i told you guys didn't i i told you i
would never
ever use the term of undying because i'm
stubborn philza felt like he was done
with minecraft forever
but what filza didn't realize was that
the end of his five-year run
was actually the start of something
better the clip of filza's unfortunate
demise was posted to the popular
subreddit live stream fails
and it exploded the outpouring of
support was
overwhelming and it wasn't long before
philza found himself
talking about his death on national
television
um what happened was i got overwhelmed
by a zombie baby zombie
very fast and it's very difficult to hit
them
and for whatever reason i assumed i
would be fine and just kept fighting it
without
placing a water bucket down to put
myself out from being on fire
um or running in a different direction
yeah it was bad and uh
what happened was i tried to escape got
hit by a skeleton which pushed me back
into the danger zone
and the spider and zombie the baby's
obviously killed me
what was probably one of the most
soul-crushing things he ever experienced
turned filza into a bonafide minecraft
celebrity in a matter of
days but i had no idea
[Music]
how big this moment would be
it has spread everywhere it is
world [ __ ] wise i i can't
get over it it's gone viral in the wake
of the tragic event
filz's live viewership jumped into the
thousands
and his growing sub count allowed him to
pursue his love of streaming
full-time giving him the opportunity to
use his newfound celebrity
for good i'm gonna be helping out with
uh teamtrees.org which is basically
let's try to get
20 million trees planted before 2020.
and twitch isn't just a workplace for
filza either
it's also where he met his wife a
special occasion i'm getting on a plane
i'm gonna get married it's happening
boys it's been a long time coming
filzo went from streaming to 20 people
on a good day
to running one of the most successful
minecraft twitch channels out there
and funnily enough all he had to do was
step over his own dead
body in order to get there no
filza was able to take the building
blocks from his old world to create an
even better one for himself
and honestly that's pretty damn cool
like me dude
[Music]
[Music]
you